mercredi matin à la chine un quartier en
périphérie de montréal
un peu avant 7h véronique fait partie de
ceux qui se rendent encore au travail au
centre ville elle emprunte un parcours
typique
elle prend d'abord sa voiture qu elle
stationne quelques kilomètres plus loin
elle s'apprête ensuite à monter dans le
train de banlieue une routine qu'elle
répétait tous les matins avant la
pandémie
maintenant elle ne le fait que deux
jours par semaine le reste du temps elle
est en télétravail nous la moitié nos
clients d'enfants sont des travailleurs
qui se destinent principalement
centre-ville de montréal
donc c'est sûr qu'avec le télétravail
beaucoup de ces gens là qui maintenant
sont à la maison
[Musique]
si vous aviez à comparer avec par
exemple l'achalandage avec un vent de la
pandémie
c'est incomparable vue complètement un
autre monde pour moi je trouve avant on
avait la place ce soir
quand même on pouvait s'asseoir mais il
y avait quand même déjà proximité de
nous le matin ou le soir j'avais
toujours déjà côté de moi de la gare de
la chine direction vendôme dans le
quartier notre dame de grâce où elle
prend le métro depuis des années
véronique qui travaille à l'université
du québec à montréal avaient un
abonnement mensuel au transport en
commun
mais elle a annulé cet abonnement ça
nous revient que - charge la dépendance
est à la fois en l1 l'uqam deux jours
semaines j'ai pas me prendre pour une
semaine au pour un mot que je peux pas
faire ça parce que je rentrerai pas dans
mon argent tresseur visiblement elle
n'est pas la seule à avoir changé ses
habitudes
[Musique]
arrivé à berri uqam c'est la station
centrale du réseau montréalais
habituellement bondées en heures de
pointe ce matin elle est pratiquement
désertes
un vide qui témoigne du défi pour les
sociétés de transport on vise dans le
fonds d'état si la fin de l'année entre
40 à 55 % d'achalandage habituel et on
vise revenir le tranquillement 2021 pour
autour de 75 80 % et pour la fin 2022 on
travaille aucune hypothèse de 95%
les usagers ont probablement disparu on
parle de la plus grande chute
d'achalandage de l'histoire du transport
en commun - d'usagé et donc moins
d'argent
selon les prévisions de l'autorité
régionale de transport métropolitain qui
finance les sociétés du grand montréal
les pertes devraient atteindre 870
millions de dollars sur trois ans c'est
énorme et les conséquences de la
deuxième vague pourrait faire exploser
la facture
vous pouvez facilement doubler l'impact
sur la période de cinq ans de presque 2
milliards de manque à gagner au niveau
des revenus le gouvernement a déjà
promis une aide d'un milliard deux cents
millions de dollars pour le transport
collectif au québec
mais qu'advient-il des grands projets
comme le rem le réseau express
métropolitains c'est le plus grand
chantier des 50 dernières années avec la
diminution d'achalandage en or at on
vraiment besoin
rien n'indique un abandon massif de
transport en commun à long terme
l'humanité depuis les cinq mille
dernières années la seule fois qu'ils
ont réellement abandonné les centres
villes
c'est avec la chute de l'empiré romain
et l'arrivée de la période médiévale
pour cet expert les travailleurs et les
étudiants reviendront au centre ville
avec les travaux et la congestion
il faut non seulement continuer de
financer le transport en commun
mais il faut même accélérer la cadence
des investissements les gens aiment
souvent annoncé la fin du monde a une
certaine mode mais la réalité
c'est que les villes sont des lieux de
création sont des lieux d'intérêt et les
gens vont y retourner dès qu'ils se
sentent en sécurité dans le métro des
employés nettoient les rentes
il y à du désinfectant pour tous selon
la stm
il n'est pas du tout dangereux de
prendre le transport en commun la santé
publique on peut dénoncer de d'éclosion
dans le transport en commun depuis le
début de la pandémie
mais pour que les gens reviennent il
faudra aussi que l'activité reprenne au
centre ville c'est une question
économique mais aussi environnemental
véronique espère que ceux qui ont décidé
de prendre la voiture reviendront aux
transports en commun
j'avoue que j'allais puis une fois la
première journée de retour en présentiel
pour me sécuriser mais après je me suis
dit on vient nos habitudes la vie
continue j'essaie je vais casser ce mot
là dessus d'abord par la pandémie à
mi-mots real au ralenti il faudra un
moment avant qu'elle ne reprenne le
rythme